the provinces in china's northeast are
suffering some of the country's worst
power cuts with cities plunged into
darkness lasting hours
it was completely dark
i can see nothing because the power is
cut from everything only when vehicles
drove past could you see lights on
around two-thirds of provinces are now
affected
it's due in part to the rising cost of
coal which means it's harder for power
plants to make a profit so they're
producing less electricity
that's affecting economic output with
some analysts predicting a slower growth
rate this year
china's older more energy hungry
industries are being hurt the hardest
but the country's leadership is on a
drive to transform to a greener more
energy efficient society and for that it
needs to move away from its reliance on
coal
gradually air pollution has been
reducing in china's major cities and
even china's neighbors like south korea
have been seeing more blue skies
but president xi jinping as he outlined
to the recent u.n general assembly wants
china to become carbon neutral by 2060
he's set ambitious targets for
provincial governments to reduce carbon
emissions
adding to the pressure to cut back on
burning coal and now with this really
tightened environmental regulation in
the background of carbon emission
reduction
there is a strong incentive for local
governments to shut down power plants
and also curb the coal production and
that's why we get here trying to strike
the balance between environmental
ambitions and economic growth with the
energy demands of the winter months just
ahead rob mcbride al jazeera hong kong